quand on a des gens qui ne croient plus
à rien et qui ne ne voit plus d'espoir
en fait sur tout ce qui leur est proposé
eh bien on voit bien que ce qu'il ya
sous la cocotte minute et sous le
couvercle finalement surgi et ressurgit
très régulièrement france aux ripailles
vous qui attend dans la vie politique
depuis très longtemps l'organe national
c'est pas revenir sur votre parcours
politique oui
précisé que ce partage pleinement je
dirais ce qui vient d'être dit par mes
deux collègues alors cela étant dit sur
coignières je suis pas très sûr de ce
que je vais dire mais au national le
front national à coignières cette grotte
de 10% ce pour ça voilà alors moi je
suis gaulliste depuis 1958 lorsque je me
suis engagé à 18 ans j'étais le plus
jeune encartés de l'umr à l'époque donc
comme vous dites ça fait très longtemps
que je suis un observateur de la vie
politique et que j'y participe et donc
en tant que gaulliste et bien il est
parfaitement clair que moi je ne peux
pas comprendre je dirais cette dérive du
front national dans notre pays et je
dois dire que malheureusement les
politiques nationales de ceux qui ont
occupé le pouvoir ces 30 dernières
années et bien de mon point de vue
participe à un petit peu à l'avènement
du front national en force
nationale il faut les écouter faux pas à
mon avis des marginalisés ou alors
rappeler les heures les plus sombres de
notre histoire etc etc pense qu'il faut
quand même les écouter et ne pas
forcément jeu bien évidemment totalement
la référence historique et un petit peu
médiatisé c'est ce qu'on voit un petit
peu partout c'est en partie vrai c'est
vrai mais il ya un vrai vote aux
électeurs blancs j'entends bien c'est
pour ça que je l'avais la différence
puisque justement par rapport à ce que
vous avez dit il faut aussi écouter
parallèlement les électeurs du front
national qui ont des choses à dire voilà
c'est tout rapprochement probable c'est
à dire que le rapprochement nous ne
l'avions pas fait encore puisque nous
étions dans une dans une
intercommunalité intermédiaires qui est
en train de se monter donc les démarches
et avec mister e et i les démarches
allaient se faire maintenant je veux
dire avec cette légitimité que nous
avons en tout cas pour se rapprocher et
que si saint-quentin enfin je veux dire
était de gauche ç'aurait été pareil on
aurait fait un rapprochement à
l'identique alors forcément le même
accueil c'est du côté de la gauche sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin c'est
un bien pour
l'autre l'autre élément a priori c'est
que on aura un basculement ce qui était
prévisible en fait le sud est du premier
tour de l'agglomération avec une
situation un petit peu nouvelle non
seulement parce que c'est la gauche qui
a tenait cette agglomération depuis
déjà des décennies mais aussi parce que
on va se retrouver avec une
agglomération où on a quatre villes de
gauche et trois villes de droite donc
forcément faudra commencer bien cohérent
chose pour vous c'est pas cohérent dans
ce que les règles ont changé insectes ce
changement aussi les règles qu'on vote
pour les élus communautaires directement
et le rapport de force change ni à un
nombre d'élus communautaires par ville
ils sont désignés par les votants dans
les communes en fonction des résultats
obtenus en société
effectivement c'est un sage c'est ce qui
explique ce changement même si les
maires donc pour l'instant pas changé on
verra si revenant bretonneux ça reste le
cas si alexis rémois moi je suis très
satisfaite de voir que dans un contexte
national que nous vivons pour le parti
socialiste ontex défaite on a réussi sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin a
conservé des villes à gauche et avec des
scores qui sont quand même assez assez
bon ce qui se passe à maurepas mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avant c'est
c'est ce qu'il faut absolument éviter en
politique si aucun randonnée
les pertes plus personne ne comprend
rien parce qu'on est on et puis sur des
projets qui n'a plus de liens étroits
entre le citoyen et politique c'est un
manque de confiance est pas moins
d'intérêt parce que les gens
s'intéressent à la politique quand ils
s'abstiennent c'est pas parce que il
n'aime pas les politiques qui n'aime pas
la politique simplement qu'ils n'ont
plus confiance aux citoyens qui n'est
plus ce contact là régulier ça devient
des gestionnaires d'une ville et non
plus des politiques au sens noble du
terme des gens qui s'occupent qui sont
proches de leurs concitoyens donc
effectivement parler de maurepas tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que ce genre
d'affaires ou en candidat se dit se
réclame d'une étiquette politique
vient d'un courant quitte ce courant
revient avec une autre dit doit enfin
les gens s'y perdre et ça n'a plus
aucune valeur que candidat certes tu
viens d'une famille politique mais aussi
un doit avoir un discours cohérents sur
le long terme et les 3 villes que l'on
vient d'étudier à savoir maurepas bois
d'arcy et saint cyr c'est des villes qui
sont une vingtaine ou une trentaine
d'années une source d'instabilité
politique maurepas historiquement était
à gauche puis ça a basculé dans les
années 80 3 si ma mémoire est bonne à à
droite puis ça rend 89 a basculé à
gauche et le maire en fait été de moins
en moins à gauche et puis bah voilà
arrive un moment où comme le dit la
représentante du parti socialiste il ya
des renouveaux qui sont nécessaires